[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to be
[Music]
there's no time 13 o clock hey it's the
Valentine's Day special it's a special
edition show really our most sound cool
though yeah it did kind of but yeah this
was actually your idea to do I was
actually gonna do female serial killers
on this show but you said you know we
should do we should do killer couples
Valentine's Day and this is something
that is always kind of fascinated
neighbors I mean really true crime
serial killers their psychology in
general has always fascinated me but
there's something about the dynamic
between a male and female couple that do
this kind of stuff yeah that just really
intrigues me like just in a horrifying
sort of way you know what yeah it's just
always kind of weirded me out but the
synergy between you know you got some
guy who is out murdering women and he
talks some other woman into hay and
serves as children yeah yeah that's
pretty bad yeah it's so it really does
seem like I mean you know one serial
killer is bad enough but then you have
like a couple actually go around oh [ __ ]
so what I wanted to do with this was I
mean there were a lot of really horrific
ones to choose from but I didn't
necessarily want to pick some of the
ones that I first thought of you know
like yeah well no once they're there
they're driven into the ground well
these are pretty well known but I mean I
didn't want to go the route of you know
like Charles Starkweather yeah
Brady and Hindley yeah very famous Fred
Andros West right ones like that I mean
the ones I picked are fairly well-known
and they usually turn up on you know
worst killer like the b-sides but yes
but I wanted to pick ones that maybe
weren't as famous as the other ones so
we'll get into that in a little bit how
many different cases we're talking about
four well I'm doing four then plus I
kind of found one that's on the news
oh there's in the news recently okay cuz
you know how I like to yeah it's gonna
be a the current event topic but before
we do that let's do our usual little
shout outs and housekeeping like we
normally do as usual my book the
faceless villain I pretty much I think I
only have two free audio codes left
maybe so if you want one get to me like
soon because I'm gonna run out yeah the
bulk of the action right now faceless
villains and unseen hand yeah both of
them still pretty much kicking ass yeah
I think it's shifted to use a lot of
sales towards faces Phil and I think now
yes and like I said I'm still working on
volume two I'm hoping to get that out
before summer time so I've been working
very hard on that one thing I've also
been thinking about doing I was talking
to a listener of the show who was
actually interested in some of my
fiction also yeah and he had wondered
now most of my fiction I published
myself under my own imprint however I do
have two novels that were published by a
small press right now at this stage
these are very difficult to get hold of
I mean I think the one that's called Red
Menace I think that only came out in
eBook format anyway but the old one that
was called bellwether which came out in
2010 did originally come out in print
but evidently I don't know if you can
get it in this country but he's in
Australia and he's like look at this and
he sent me a screenshot and the print
version of it is 138 ya know like this
is like a 200 page book right so after
is going through my contracts and
everything like that I think that I have
the the legal right now that the
copyright has since reverted to me I
believe it's five years after
publication and census has published in
2010 that I should be able to so publish
to publish it myself with my own cover
art and stuff like that so I might be
doing that and acts
what I might do is I have a bunch of
unpublished short stories and stuff like
that so I might kind of put it all
together yeah one compilation just so
you feel like you're getting more for
your money yeah and we think the other
one may come up underneath that contract
in another couple of months - no it'll
be no it'll be yeah it'll be late next
year yes yeah sue is published in late
2014 so right we think it'd be a good
idea that turn them into basically a 400
page product which is the main story and
then some short story short stories and
that offer from an e-book print book and
audio because you don't really have any
audio yet and I bet you there's a lot of
demand for yes probably
I would actually eventually like to get
all my fiction on audiobook - I just
haven't got around to doing it here
because I have so many and you know with
the fig if we can get the fiction on
audiobook we can give out free write
codes for it yeah which one actually
launched those books pretty well I think
the relaunch them so eventually I will
get around to doing like I said I I did
i want to get faithfuls mellon the three
bottoms of that kind of done by this
year are the thing I want to do is I
want to I want to get a better
microphone - actually for that yeah I
with us - yeah cuz we really got to get
audio book down yeah well well you know
I mean this microphone is kind of if we
know anybody out there that wants to
donate a good microphone yeah this one I
think this is always 150 bucks
yeah they got guys out there that have
real nice microphones gitarama not do
anything with it yeah yeah so you know
anybody got some free books yeah okay so
what else
Oh our latest movie review was the
original West world from 1973 starring a
little burner so if you want to check
that out that's up there if you haven't
seen it already
also I said last week that I have three
new shirt designs on ours Apple Store
which is Azal dot-com flash 13 o'clock
yeah I finally got a Snake Plissken
shirt coming - yeah yeah he's been
wanting one for so long but yeah I made
one I made a couple haunting ones
that raccoon give a picture of the sink
listen sure somewhere yeah yeah show
them yeah I put it in one of the other
really cool it's a Cobra kind of like
out of the Ford Cobra logo yeah but it
just says Plissken oh yeah it looks
really cool you can't really say snake
you can only say yeah I don't want to
get my but it's a black shirt looks
really cool yeah but so those are up
there if you want to check those out
also remember if you would like to
support the show to check out our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcasts I've started trying
to put more exclusive content up there
because I know I've kind of been
neglecting it because I run out of time
to do [ __ ] but um I've been putting up
some short stories reviews things like
that and I'm gonna try and put up at
least one thing a week hopefully two
things a week so we'll see how that goes
yeah and also I would like to give a
particular shadow to our newest patron
whose name is Tom okay no relation to
you it's definitely the same first name
related yeah but you're not related but
because the spelling is different okay
so that's how that works
yeah but yes so thank you Tom and
welcome to our patreon page and hope
you're enjoying the shows so now that
we've got all that other way let's get
to our little news story here and like I
said since we're doing a killer couples
theme this seems like a good short
little story - yeah for all you
lovebirds now this actually took place
in Germany and I found this story in The
Times which I think it's the London
Times this was dated February 8th so
there's this couple and I guess it's
their not convicted yet they don't give
their last names I guess that's a that's
a law thing there because their names
are only given as Jonah or jana f who is
38 years old and her boyfriend Rene M
who is 28 and they're from a very small
town in western Germany yeah I remember
this yeah I know yes so I loved the
article says while they're both
undergoing psychiatric treatment I don't
know if that means they are both in a
mental hospital
I guess it's outpatient because there
were a lot of runaround but yes so they
met
while they're undergoing psychiatric
treatment and they bonded over a shared
love of gory horror movies and true
crime TV shows yes they're making our
listeners already look bad that's people
like me a bad name there you go cuz look
I love glory horror movies I love true
crime shows I'd never kill anyone over
the life unless they came at me first
yeah well that's not the fast right well
I would do that that's self-defense but
I'm not we used up defense defense of
others all that [ __ ] I'm just but other
than that I you know I'm fascinated by
this [ __ ] but I would never do it
personally I'm just not that kind of
person but apparently these two bozos
are into that so they decide their
favorite show is wicked attraction which
we have over here it's on investigation
discovery and actually a couple of some
of the couples that we're talking about
today I watched a bunch of documentaries
the couples on that very show so they
they show it in Germany and it's called
killer couples over there but it's the
same show and they decide that they're
gonna pull Natural Born Killers of
Mickey Mallory's night or whatever and
they're gonna be we're gonna be
sweetheart serial killers that's their
aspiration from life [ __ ] losers which
yeah why would I don't get that but
whatever all right
so these do you decide that they're
gonna be [ __ ] Bonnie and Clyde or
whatever yeah so apparently their first
victim because I guess they wanted to
start slow I suppose yeah they're gonna
start off on novice settings well yes so
they decide that the guy's mom had an 81
year old neighbor oh [ __ ] yeah like an
old lady yeah and they figure oh well
she must have money in her house cuz you
know how how rich those little cattle
horses old ladies are that live in yeah
where so they decide they're gonna start
with her and this is gonna start their
crime spree and they're gonna be famous
and [ __ ] like that
so they go in her house the man stabbed
her in the neck from behind like stabs
on the back in the neck and then the
woman attacks her from the front so
they're double-teaming this poor old
woman yeah they stabbed the old woman 11
times
when she died what bravery right yeah
[ __ ] at least pick on yeah but you know
like I said so you know these [ __ ]
so evidently I don't even know if they
got any money from this woman's house
Bry not the article says all they stole
was two wedding rings okay
then they took off to Spain yeah then
they they pawned the wedding rings to
probably $75 each although yes sobolik
evidently as soon as they get to Spain
they're caught like almost immediately
and then you know what I mean and then
they got extradited and everything like
that so their trial just started this
week master criminals right yes so how
was how was that serial killing mess you
killed one old horrible woman
that'll be ashamed use and got caught
you know what yeah your heads right I'm
not saying like I'm not saying that oh
you should be a serial killer oh you
know like that but I'm here come on well
they all think that they're gonna be
Hannibal Lecter right serial killers
like Hannibal Lecter don't really exist
no that's a fictional that's a fictional
thing yeah like yeah some of them are
smart and everything but the problem I
think a lot of serial killers they're
graded on a curve too well yeah and also
I think a lot of them think they're a
lot smarter than a X ray and you'll see
that with some of our some of our people
here that we're talking about so now I
had like four different couples I wanted
to cover these are just ones I picked
because I found them interesting for one
reason they're not there no order not
really
I just kind of I honestly I wanted to
talk about these two first because for
some reason this case just intrigues me
a lot and I'm not sure exactly why okay
I think it's because they don't really
you know I'm not saying there's like a
[ __ ] formula for serial killer things
like that but they seem so not like the
normal she doesn't I mean he seems we
must be talking about the cannon Barbie
yes I'm talking about Paul Bernardo and
Malka yeah the Barbie and Ken killers
and Barbie killers however you want to
say yeah these two I don't know why I
find them so fascinating and there are
actually there exactly actually quite a
few documentaries about these two
because they look normal
it's that - it's that but it's also
because he doesn't really fascinate me
that much because he just sounds like an
arrogant yuppie [ __ ] right but she
does because she seemed totally normal
yeah and she went along with this and
she went along with it I've heard
stories about the case I'm not real from
this oh yeah yeah well I read a bunch of
[ __ ] and watched a bunch of
documentaries about it if tell our
audience is that what we present these
cases we're not adding anything to them
we're not like super experts on these
cases we're presenting them for your
study I guess you'd be a good way to
play you know be interested in the case
you can find more out about yourself
well yeah that's what I mean like I said
I just pick stuff that I find is
interesting the interesting thing too
about this because there was kind of a
lot of information about these two it's
interesting how different documentaries
have different details and there are
things that kind of turn up so you know
you never really I you know you never
really don't know one documentaries
gonna sensationalize a little bit more
than the other or maybe they have access
to a different witness yes all right so
let's talk a little bit about now Paul
Bernardo was okay now like I said this
is kind of the dynamic of the killer
couples that always kind of interest me
is that I always wonder if in a lot of
these cases had these women not hooked
up with these particular men hmm would
they have killed anyone if left to their
own devices I'm gonna say wrap down my
head no no in this case I don't think so
now I'm not exonerating her she isn't
she is a huge piece of [ __ ] and she
should be held responsible because she
was totally into it after she but if she
had not met him if there was some
alternate timeline I don't think she
would have become a murderer I don't
think she would have most
cases I've heard about when I read the
details about them
I don't think normally that they would
go to killed anyone right it's usually
what happens is the synergy builds on
yeah clean the man on the woman yet and
she gets sucked into it right and
becomes a part of it sometimes they
start to take kind of an an active role
or a dominant role in a if they have a
taste for it you know yeah it's rare
that's kind of what and I think that's
what happened in this time I think
there's kind of bullied into it yeah
where she discovered or she discovered
that she like you said she was into it
or something sport that she might not
have ever explored or anything like that
now Paul Bernardo now he was a piece of
[ __ ] before he ever met her you know I'm
not saying that he wouldn't have killed
because I think he would ask he didn't
kill anyone until after he met her but
he was for sure a multiple rapist right
way before he met her okay
now Paul Bernardo he had kind of a he
was a good-looking kid blond kid soda
happy little boys and Boy Scouts and all
that other [ __ ] they seems very well
behaved very well mannered stuff but his
family like was kind of [ __ ] up now
his dad or the man he thought he was his
dad for his entire childhood was a sex
offender he was a peeping tom pedophile
he molested one of Palmeiras sisters so
you know that wasn't great he was also
abusive toward Paul Bernard s mother
right so not a great situation there now
evidently one pub round it was sixteen
years old his mother admitted that this
pedophile in their house was not his
real dad that Paul Bernardo had actually
been conceived but his mom had an affair
with an with an old boyfriend so after
that point it seems like Paul Bernardo
started really hating his mother calling
her a [ __ ] and all this energy which
okay whatever
yeah um no no [ __ ] complex yeah yeah he
definitely seemed to have had that Bundy
had that yeah right but and he seems
like the same type of guy and he seems
very arrogant very he was he works for
Amway and he got super into him with
yeah and they got super into that
wholesale sell composure Zig Ziglar so
so we got very into that and we have a
oh that's a Colton yeah
so my Zinta yeah he was very attractive
that he was very into like um pickup
artist type stuff him or all his friends
you know using that kind of [ __ ] now
starting in 87 that they know of he
started attacking teenage girls normally
he was a stranger rapist he wasn't a
date rapist or nothing he would stalk
girls he would look in their windows
they would get off buses from school or
something like that he would grab him
and drag him in the bushes [ __ ] like
that so you even know this crowd yeah
now this went on for a long time and
there were so many attacks this was in
Ontario yeah in Toronto this a suburb of
Toronto called Scarborough so he became
although they didn't know this was him
at the time he was known as the
Scarborough rapist and it was a big deal
like the teenage girls were like
terrified to like walk around the
streets and sell their cuz he was just
snatching because he was doing this well
he was a little bit older I think he was
late teens early 20s something like that
there there's just a huge list if you
look on poverty was [ __ ] Wikipedia
page there's a huge list of and this is
just the ones they know of right I mean
because after he got arrested and [ __ ]
like that they look back and they think
that there's other rapes and murders
that they didn't ever pin on him did he
kill him not until after he got together
with Carla okay and he was kind of
raping the whole time rape is gonna
bring yeah
so he meets Karla Homolka in 1987 late
1987 she really loved animals and all
the stuff like I said she was a totally
normal kids you totally know shoot very
pretty very popular should let the
boyfriends did good in school
her family was totally normal [ __ ] two
sisters [ __ ] like that so nothing in her
past that would suggest you know the way
that her [ __ ] would go right so she
meets him she worked in a veterinary
office or something like that so she
goes to she's 17 years old in 1987 and
she is at a pet store conference and
Paul Bernardo also happens to be at the
same I don't know if he's in the same
conference in similar
tell or whatever but there in this
restaurant hotel and they kind of see
each other and friends of theirs that
were there so it was like immediate like
electricity like it's almost like hey
psycho psycho you know I mean it was
kind of like that I mean nobody knew
they were psychos until later but I'm
just saying so it seemed like they were
kind of immediately and immediately they
meet they hit it off they're up in the
hotel room having sex or whatever now
from the first she just adored him she
thought he was like the perfect man her
parents thought that he was the perfect
man he had been an accountant that's
what his degree was in later on he would
actually quit his job as the counter he
got fired or something like that and
then started making his money by
smuggling cigarettes across the
candidate USA border which I don't know
why why would you have to smuggle
cigarettes e-cigarettes in Canada so
yeah so he might never make ten days off
for gardeners yeah so he started doing
that without really telling anybody but
here was the thing though I don't know
if he was physically abusive from the
first but he was for sure emotionally
abusive and she seemed to have some
self-esteem issues right
they found her diary later on where she
would say things like you know that she
always had to keep all happy to never
argue with him remember you're fat
remember you're ugly remember you're fat
yeah like you know what I mean she's
like I don't know why I keep writing
this I never changed like that so yeah
cuz from what I remember seeing pictures
every she went that she wasn't fat or
ugly at all he was just using that
together neither skin yeah she was she
was just trying to manipulate her by you
know essentially emotionally abusing her
or tearing her down and things like that
so like I said not excusing her in any
manner because what she did later was
pretty [ __ ] horrific also but yeah so
these two hit it off they make plans to
get married now as I said this whole
time he's been raping girls I don't know
how much of that she knew beforehand
right the first person they actually
killed was Karla Homolka
15 year old sister Tammy yeah this is
the part of the story there this is
[ __ ] up yeah how this so okay so what
happens is evidently Paul Bernardo had
been giving Carlos [ __ ] because she was
not
virgin yes right then like she he was
like he was so disappointed yeah you
know he wasn't her first sense or way
there was this again like late eighties
early nineties damn yeah guy supposedly
beyond that at that time I know I use it
yeah back on those days if you were a
virgin then you know this mean you
weren't any good well yeah that's what
most people would think that's what
normal people with right yeah so
evidently she makes plans and he has
been kind of drooling over the 15 year
old sister he goes in her room when
she's sleeping and jerks off he's like
watching her through the windows and
this is it Carla knows about this right
right so she finally says well for
Christmas I'll give you Tammy's
virginity dang so it's two days before
Christmas there in Carla and Tammy's
parents house yeah they're having a
Christmas party the parents and the
other sister go to bed
they give the fifteen-year-old like rum
and eggnog or whatever and she has
stolen like a bunch of sedatives like
halothane and stuff like that from the
[ __ ] room that clinic where she
worked animal tranquilizer yeah and they
knock her ass out they take her down to
the basement
Carla videotapes him raping her yeah
Carla is like and also hold it's like a
fang over her mouth like to keep her
from waking up like a like a rag with
[ __ ] chloroform or whatever it was at
it and then Carla rapes the sister yeah
it's out weird [ __ ] right now they
didn't mean to kill her right what ended
up happening was that the sensei had
given her so much alcohol and drugs and
said like that she starts to vomit and
she starts to choke on the vomit yeah so
they try to revive her and they can't so
then she dies and then they're like oh
[ __ ] we have to clean the basement
up and then we'll call the ambulance
that's what they did
they vacuumed the basement they did
their laundry they didn't like all this
other [ __ ] right the family sleeping
upstairs yeah they called the ambulance
there
it's not hiding the depth and everything
the mom and dad sit upstairs yeah so
they come and they get Tammy and she's
dead obviously even though she had like
a chemical burn on her face from where
the rag was they just attributed her
death to an accident Oh she'd been drunk
and she vomited and choked on her own
vomit [ __ ] happens
so Karla and Paul were all like oh we
tried to revive her and all this other
[ __ ]
so they got away with that [ __ ] so the
end just over enough yeah well no to
Zach Zach you were sick at other point
that at other points that Carla would
sometimes bring home like even
especially after Tammy died
Carla felt bad because she's like oh we
don't have Tammy around to play okay now
there's also video tape of Carla
dressing up in Tammy's clothing and the
two of them having sex and like her
pretending to be her sister after this
is nasty and then she's this other
fifteen-year-old girl who they don't say
heard they never say her name so Jane
Doe because she didn't want to be
identified and Carla brings her to the
house they do the same thing with her
they drugged her a rape her videotape
and everything like that but then they
let her go but see she doesn't remember
that she was raped because she was
[ __ ] knocked out right she just
thought she came over and she was
drinking with them with them with the
older kids so that happened to sick
people right now at some point during
all this they have this big lavish
wedding and there's video tape of it and
some of the documentaries and it's super
[ __ ] creepy it's like the late 80s
early night is this wedding you've ever
seen it's just all big hair and taffeta
and tulle and big puffy sleeves they
they come riding in on like a [ __ ]
horse-drawn carriage and [ __ ] like that
it's revolting yeah so yes so these two
[ __ ] heels are like coming in this big
[ __ ] wedding and everything like that
meanwhile all this written out either
shortly before or shortly after they get
married Paul Bernardo is out on a
mission to steal some license plates for
me like you do like you do yeah and he
happens to see this girl Leslie Mahaffy
and she was 14 years old
now she had just been walking home from
her she had a friend named Chris that
had died in
our accident she had been in his wake
now she had walked home but she was past
curfew so I guess she got locked out I
don't know if her parents locked her out
to be mean or she just didn't have the
keys or whatever so she was like stuck
in her backyard like [ __ ] I'm locked out
of my house Paul Bernardo sees her in
the backyard and he pulls up and he's
like hey what happened to you she's like
I got like that my house and she says
hey you got a cigarette and he's like
yeah they're my car so he pulls her in
the car he takes her back to the house
where Carla is and they they keep her
for like 24 hours rape her multiple
times then they end up strangling her
cutting up her body with a circular saw
putting the pieces in blocks of concrete
yeah and dropping them into Lake Gibson
okay the problem was that one of the
blocks was too large for they couldn't
push it far enough into the water so
that was the problem I think there's a
lot of frost well yeah from there from
there so one of the blocks was still
kind of sticking out and a man and his
son that were out fishing saw it and
thought it looked funny because it was
something weird leaking out of the side
so at that stage they found the body now
I think they found the body on the same
day their wedding or something like that
it was like right around the same time
then and they decided that they were
gonna do it again
cuz it was so fun the first time I guess
so they're driving around looking for a
victim they see a fifteen-year-old girl
named Kristen French and she's walking
home from she's like in Catholic school
isn't like that she walking home from
school so they pull into a church
parking lot and Carla gets out of the
car she's got a map she oh we're lost we
need directions baba and the girls like
okay you know it's a woman she doesn't
like she's not freaked out or anything
like that so while she's talking to
Carla
Paul sneaks up behind her puts a knife
to her back it was like getting in car
they stick her in the car and take her
to their house they keep Kristen French
for three days that they know they don't
live alone do they well they know at
some point they bought they got their
own house they have a house
right yes so I forgot to mention that
but yeah they do have to run how soon
all right
so they take Kristen French to their
house proceeded to rape her for three
days they show heard the videotape of
them murdering raping and murdering
Leslie Mahaffy and various other things
and finally they end up strangling her
and dumping her body in a ditch very
near the cemetery where Leslie Mahaffy
was buried man that'd be bad day you're
in the custody these two these murderers
right and they show you what they did to
the other girl that's what I mean can
you imagine god that poor [ __ ] girl
yeah that's horrible these people are
perverts man no yeah yeah so although
that's nothing compared to what would
happen if I got a holy man so bad this
hearing so basically how they ended up
getting caught was that now I believe
like I said there's there's a lot of
information about them and some of the
documentaries say various things and so
you know the details in general are
pretty similar but you know little
details are different I think what ended
up happening was that Paul Bernardo got
pissed off at Karla because of the whole
Leslie Mahaffy body being discovered in
the concrete because evidently the
concrete was Carla's idea and from his
point of view she had [ __ ] it up they
weren't supposed to find the bodies or
whatever even though he bought the
concrete because they found the receipts
right so you know whatever it's gotta
blame somebody well ya can't blame the
woman right because it's also used to
blow cuz it's always it's always our
fault but yeah so he ends up beating
Karla severely so much so that she has
to go to the emergency room and there's
like pictures of her she has two pews
black eyes she's a broken rib she has
all this other stuff and apparently he
beats the [ __ ] out of her way that
flashlight so she goes the emergency
room she finally reports the police
she's going to report and she says she's
a battered spouse her parents intervene
now at this point it should be noted
that Paul Bernardo was questioned for
the Scarborough rapist case because a
lot of the victims had described what he
looked like
so the police sketch that a bunch of the
sexual assault victims from previously
had given to the police if you see the
picture of the police sketch it looks
just
[ __ ] like him right eat so much so
that even some of his friends like
teased it about it man looks just like
yeah and actually the sister of one of
his friends called the cops that looks
just like now when they did question him
about the Scarborough rapes like
previously but and he willingly gave a
DNA sample but see the thing was that
they had so many other suspects and so
many other DNA samples and this was like
1991 or some [ __ ] like that or 1990 and
you know they can't do a DNA test quick
like now so it took that long so it took
a like two years before they had
actually got to his day at a sample and
matched it to the DNA this suit they
figured out that he was the Scarborough
rapist and that was about the same time
that Karla got beat up and left him and
decided that she was going to tell them
about now at first she only was talking
about the spousal abuse but then when
they connected him with the Scarborough
rapist and stuff like that then she
started to say okay well we're
responsible for Leslie Mahaffy and
Kristen French and she said and we have
video tapes to prove it now the cops
went to search the house but they
couldn't find the videotapes so they
searched the house for like it was like
some ridiculous amount of time like more
than two months right and they they just
tore this house up and they couldn't
find these videotapes
so essentially even though they knew he
was he had done the rapes they didn't
have the physical evidence to tie him to
the murders they just had her word right
so but they did need her testimony and
she did say that there were some
videotapes that they're like okay so
what they did was they told her that if
you will testify against him then we
will give you away
lesser charge right what they were gonna
do was give her 12 years for
manslaughter and that was it
she had a week to think about it and so
she decided to take it and she told
police everything okay so she ended up
getting 12 years now Paul Bernardo goes
on trial and after he is you know he's
given life and
Prison right he was I don't even
remember how many [ __ ] murders I
think it was [ __ ] three murders and
it's a bunch of rapes yeah and there
were actually a bunch there there were a
couple of rapes and murders that she
described that they never could pin on
him or they never found the people or
whatever but what ended up happening was
that after she had already done the deal
for 12 years
they found the videotapes yeah and they
watched them yeah and but she was super
into it which is not what she told the
police she just said he bullied me into
it I'm just weird because she knew that
the videotapes were there maybe she
didn't remember it going down exactly
you know but you know she's in there in
on it
yeah you know well you know how you know
if she would've gone she would have been
she'd have been like oh well I was
scared that's it and like I said trying
to act denying that he didn't beat her
up at least that one time which kind of
implies to me that he probably had beat
her up on previous occasions because
that's not usually a one-time thing he
was for sure emotionally abusive but I
mean on the tape she seems like she's
super into and seriously raping your own
sister yeah isn't that on videotape
letting your husband yeah it was on the
tape - yes that was on tape - issues
yeah things what the cops see this it's
like that is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] so like
I said now she was released from prison
changed her name although everyone knows
what her name was changed - because she
had to tell the cops about her name she
is subsequently married again she had a
couple of kids the Canadian public were
not pleased with how she got off they
the media called it the deal with the
devil they're glad that Paul Bernardo is
obviously never going to get out but the
fact that she got off scot-free and is
now having a normal life especially
after details about the videotapes got
out that was really terrible for a lot
of people she subsequently moved to
Quebec and I think then she moved to the
Antilles what's weird about these women
that end up with these serial killers is
that town reminds me of some of the
women that I've known
that were in abusive relationships yeah
some women actually kind of get addicted
to it yeah I guess they're use to it
they're used to it although you know
there are some that you know it's it's
kind of like with you if you're nice to
them then they don't respect you
yeah because they have a bunch of self
self-image problems yeah yeah and then
what's weird is that they'll take the
abuse but then the abuse rolls downhill
they'll beat the children so I think you
know the guy's abusive to the woman
who's trying to please him and then she
abuses the victims right along with him
yeah weird the another interesting thing
that I wanted to note about this case
and and another thing that kind of backs
up my assertion that I don't think she
would have become a killer if she hadn't
hooked up with this guy he was given the
infamous psychopathy checklist CNN by
psychiatrist
he scored very high 35 out of 40 yeah
she only scored five at at 40 which um I
felt like I said I thought that was very
interesting but but like I said in this
case it was so [ __ ] up I mean some of
the cases that I'm gonna discuss on the
second half of the show actually I think
all of them the the women were abused
either by the person by the guy or by
their families previously so we're
probably used to abusive situations that
were just like well that's just how it
goes and so that was like the only thing
they could relate to weak people weak
people get off on power trips
yeah and you know I mean and if you beat
on a woman that she's already kind of
weak then she can get off on a power
trip I think that's what it is yeah and
I definitely life and death over
somebody else yeah it makes them feel
better for their weaknesses yeah I
definitely do think that was at play
here but like I said Paul Bernardo is
still in prison in Canada Karla Homolka
has since changed her name and married
and is living a relatively normal life
yes Paul Bernardo yep all right hey Paul
your [ __ ] balls pretty much well [ __ ]
all the horrify happy Valentine's Day
everybody
oh we gotta do break yeah okay this
shows gonna go long but you know they
all need to probably love it well that's
kind of a special analogized valentine's
day yeah one I didn't want to like give
short shrift any of the cases but okay
that one will probably go on the longest
because for some reason that one was
fascinating maybe just because they seem
so normal right and they were just so it
looks normal
yeah they look normal but yeah so it's
just weird seeing pictures of a men of
their wedding and stuff and know that
they were doing all that [ __ ] behind the
scenes so yeah let's take a break right
now and then we get back I'm gonna
discuss three more cases of killer
couples we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now from the Ken and Barbie tailors
let's talk about the grandparents these
two now this isn't a fascinating case
this is the case of ray and Faye
Copeland's all right okay now these two
at the time of their imprisonment were
the two oldest people to be put on death
row ha but there is still some
controversy about how much Faye Copeland
was involved in the serial killing okay
ray much like Paul Bernardo was a piece
of [ __ ] before he ever met his wife he
grew up during the Depression I grew up
in a farm family this was in Missouri
pretty much immediately mostly not
murder
mostly larceny check-forging things like
that you know damn type stuff he ended
up he met Faye in 1940 and they married
later that year now one documentary that
I saw because I watched several
documentaries about these two as well
one documentary I saw said that ray
Copeland actually I think he was ohm in
his mid-20s when he married Faye
she was 19 that he actually tried to
rape phase sister okay shortly after
boobs only one documentary said that
though I don't think that was on the
Wikipedia page but I did see that that
was mentioned so this guy was quite a
catch yeah and he was one of the he
seemed very arrogant he was kind of one
of those oh I have so much money and all
this other stuff even though he didn't
really have a pot to piss in and
everything he had he
right he was you know he would steal
cattle and like I said check forging and
stuff like that so he started so this
whole scam that he started now him and
Faye they ended up having five kids they
they had this farm and everything they
both worked on the farm he also did odd
jobs and other people's farms and she
also had another job I think she cleaned
hotels or something like that so you
know this is kind of your hard-working
little Midwestern family or whatever is
Mazzara in Missouri so ray Copeland
starts a little check-forging stance
alright because he had been arrested so
many times for his little check-forging
shenanigans he really wasn't allowed to
go and buy cattle at auctions and stuff
like that so what he started doing was
he would go to homeless shelters and
church missions and stuff like that and
he would find guys there drifters and he
would say hey I will pay you $50 a day
and give you room and board
if you come with me you can stay in my
house I'll take you to the cattle
auctions and you bid on the cattle for
me he's like I'm deaf you know I can't
really hear I can't hear the auction
I'm blah-dee-blah so I mean a lot of the
guys where I got me fifty dollars a day
that's a pretty good haul and dairymen
born back in those days yeah you would
get fed like you know they was there
cooking and stuff so some of them took
them up on the offer
now the problem began when there were
kind of two investigations going on
simultaneously and what ended up
happening was there was a guy named
Dennis Murphy and he had apparently
passed some bad checks because this is
what ray Copeland would do he would take
the drifter to the bank he would give
them $200 to open a checking account and
then he would take them to the cattle
auction and he said okay bid on that cow
and write the check out for however much
it was and then will pay for it but then
it would bounce obviously but by the
time it bounced he would have sold the
cattle to someone else you know for a
markup or whatever so that was his whole
scam right now the guy who wrote the
check he let that guy live at first at
first
okay but see what see some of the people
got away right there were two
investigations going on and they thought
like Dennis Murphy was the first one I
think the other one was named Wayne
Warner so there were these two
investigations going on with the
different counties like this one cop was
like we're looking for this guy named
Dennis Murphy for passing a bad check in
a cattle auction these other guys like
we're looking for a guy named Wayne
Warner for passing a bad check and
cattle auction but they noticed that
both of the both of these guys had been
associated with ray Copeland
okay so then later on here comes this
guy named Jack McCormick and he calls
the Crime Stoppers Hotline and he says
this guy ray Copeland came to me opened
a checking account in my name he gave me
$200 for the checking account and then
he told me to bid on a cow that was
$2,000 so I made out the check he's like
but then I was kind of freaking out
because it's like there's not two
thousand dollars in that account so it's
gonna bounce so he started getting
suspicious then he says he's like I'm
back at the farm he's like take me back
to the farm so they go back to the farm
and Ray Copeland says to him oh there's
a raccoon out in the barn I need you to
like poke the hay bale with a stick and
like get him to come out and I'll shoot
him right yeah so the guys in there and
he's like are you sure that the raccoon
is in here and here's that raccoon the
perfect opportunity
there we go so yeah so then Jack
McCormick says then I turn around and
see that Ray Copeland is pointing the
gun that's me oh yeah he's the racoon
yeah so he's like yeah I'm out right now
one interesting thing is that Jack
McCormick when he called Crimestoppers
he actually told the cops that he had
seen human remains on the farm right
this later turned out to be a lie but it
actually helped in finding the actual
human yeah he knew there's dead guys out
there see here's the [ __ ] okay ray
Copeland if then he's like in his
[ __ ] 70s right he's a crotchety
grumpy old man yeah he's apparently very
abusive toward his wife and his children
most of the documentaries they have one
son I think his name is Al and he's on a
bunch of them and he hasn't even called
the guy dad really he just brought ray
and he says you know he was he was a
[ __ ] right just a total violent
douchebag so what he's doing it this
this kills me this right here this this
arrogance okay that he says he goes and
picks up these homeless guys and stuff
like that and he says oh well they're
not worth anything they should just be
shot because they're like using up his
tax money and stuff like that
even though this [ __ ] has been his
entire life stealing his tax my he
hasn't paid okay when he does it though
I can just kill them because they're
like mooching off the system even though
that's exactly what the [ __ ] is a he
does right yeah and I was just like yeah
so anyway yeah
okay so what is it he's not mooching off
the system he's straight-up stealing
he's just stealing from other people
deal and again killing people yes so
yeah so it turns out once they've done
all the investigation everything like
that they end up arresting him and his
wife now there is some question about
how much they knew about this
the reason they think she was involved
is because when they searched the house
and they did end up finding five bodies
and like I said Jack McCormick he said
that there were human remains on the
farm so the cops did actually look into
Ray Copeland's passes that yet maybe we
should go check that out they searched
his whole
farm everything they didn't find
anything hmm but see the media that
surrounded the case people had no love
for ray Copeland in that community
because they said you know he was an
[ __ ] so right they're not you know
they're not gonna [ __ ] cover up for
him or anything like that so a bunch of
people came forward and said oh well he
worked at this barn or he helped mend
this fence or whatever so they knew well
maybe let's go to these other places
where he was working and dig through
there so they did get this one other
person's barn that he had been working
at and they find three bodies yeah right
next to each other so at this stage ray
Copeland is already in custody right and
he tries to wangle his way out of it by
saying cuz the cops are like hey we
found these three bodies he's like oh
you know I was in this restaurant and I
heard these three guys like I overheard
them talking and they said that they had
killed this guy and they dumped his body
down a well like they tied a concrete
block to him and I've termed out a well
and stuff like that so he's like just
heard that the rest yeah he just heard
it a restaurant wasn't him or anything
now that I heard that she has a
restaurant so the cops like okay so
there's a body in there and he's like
yeah he's like well who is he so I don't
know and then you can see like clips at
the of the interview all right so they
go and of course there's a body in that
shirt now about a hundred yards away
they found another body these two bodies
were Dennis Murphy and Wayne Warner the
two initial guys who the check fraud
that they were investigating so they
found their two bodies now when they
searched the Copeland farm they not only
found clothing that did not belong to
anyone that lived in the anyone then the
family and some of them had like last
names like round the tags because these
guys have come from homeless shelters so
they had to have you know name tags
they're close to other people take them
and stuff so they found clothes not
belong they found a quilt that was made
out of some of the clothing they also
found a little list and it had all these
people names all these guys names on it
now some of the names next to them they
said back now those people when they
investigated those those people were
still alive right and these were
evidently people when they questioned
these people they said yeah this farmer
ray Copeland
approached me and wanted me to work for
him and stuff but I said no or they go
away or whatever
now the other names have little X's next
to them and these people day ones that
were dead good day now the problem was
ray Copeland was illiterate and could
not write okay so this handwriting
analysis it was phase hand right yes use
no notic she's being the accountant
now here's so they were both arrested
Fanny would actually not she said she
didn't know anything about it she said I
just did whatever he told me to do he
you know he later it came out that he
was super abusive toward not only her
but also the children but she would not
say anything against him she would not
so really it I mean it went on a long
time and she actually ended up going to
counseling and talking to a psychiatrist
now the psychiatrist was supposed to
testify at her trial that she had
battered women's syndrome and that he
had essentially abused her for so long
that she just didn't even question him
and he if he told her hey write these
names down and xx to him and she would
just do it and not ask him about it and
so she said it's possible that she
didn't really know what he was up to
right just had her write it down that he
just had her right so there is still
that possibility right like I said she
would not have anything said against him
however there was some kind of legal
technicality some kind of misfiled paper
workers now gotten a psychiatrist was
not allowed to testify so really other
than that they didn't have much else to
go on I mean they had this piece of
paper with her handwriting on it they
had this quilt that she had made out of
the clothes she lived there she cooked
her these men that lived there and stuff
so they said well there's no way that
she couldn't have known so she got the
death penalty and a couple of days later
if they tried them separately yeah ray
Copeland a so how'd they do in court
right and the lawyer says she got the
death penalty you know I was five times
a bursary murder and Ray was totally
emotionless oh well that happens to some
oh he thinks he's not gonna get him Yeah
right so yeah so he goes to trial
I think they deliberated like three
hours yeah
yeah yes he was only in prison for two
years and he died of a stroke okay now
that the sentence was never carried out
right yeah because he I mean he was old
man right now she actually ended up
serving 12 years and then she had a
stroke she didn't die but she was
partially paralyzed and at that stage
after he died she started to open up a
lot more about the abuse and everything
like that what she would not talk about
right beforehand like she would not have
anything said against him and even in
interviews like given later on just like
he's the love of my life I would have
done anything and stuff like that it was
pretty weird
so she was partially paralyzed by a
stroke after serving 12 years and
finally she was commuted to a life
sentence and then they let her go to a
nursing home she was still under you
know your surveillance and stuff but
they let her go to a nursing home she
did wanna die in prison and she did
eventually end up dying but as I said
there's very the interview that because
one of their sons they had five kids but
one of their sons al is on a couple of
the different documentaries and he said
now I don't know if she knew what he was
doing but he's like you will never
convince me that she was part of it that
she took part in the murders right it's
like she might have known and was like
afraid to say anything right or
something like that but he said you will
never convince me that she helped him
kill those people and and like I said
there were a few more names on that list
that X's by them whose bodies they never
found okay so they did find five bodies
and that was what ended up with that but
but yes yes so all those people in death
rows but as far as I know they still
might be alright so this show probably
is gonna run a little long without that
so I'm gonna show these last few cases I
might not get into as much detail just
because I don't want this to be like
right like that first case is long yeah
well I figured it would be just because
for some reason that wouldn't fascinates
me a lot but that one probably could
have done that of just one whole show
yeah probably
okay so what's this one of us so this
one is the case of Alton Coleman and
Deborah Brown never heard of it
this was more of a crime spree era this
happened over a little more it was of
like a 54 days spree okay again like in
many other cases
this guy was a piece of [ __ ] before he
ever met the girl Alton Coleman was
actually he kind of had a messed up
childhood to be born
very poor his mother was a prostitute
his grandmother was apparently a voodoo
queen something like that this was in
the Midwest and Illinois so he had
actually been jailed many times for
sexual assault and it so happened that
he was due to go on trial for raping a
fourteen-year-old girl when him and his
new girlfriend decided to go on a rape
and murder spree okay so Deborah Brown
is the girlfriend now she also had a
terrible home life abuse neglect various
things of that nature she had did not
have any kind of criminal record no kind
of anything like that but she had a very
low IQ she was mildly mentally [ __ ]
but could still function and things of
that nature now she was engaged to
another man when she met Alton Coleman
but he was very by all accounts was very
charming you know he was very very slick
and I think in her he saw someone that
was again easily manipulated so they
ended up starting a relationship now
these two are particularly horrible too
because these two killed not only I mean
they killed a bunch of little kids but
these two would kill pretty much anybody
Alton would kill for sexual pleasure
because he would usually rape the little
girls and sometimes the women but then
they would also kill men they would kill
people they would kill if they needed
their [ __ ] right so these two were
basically spree killers okay their first
murder was that of Vernita wheat who was
nine years old they took her from
Kenosha Wisconsin Ollie Coleman had
befriended the girl's mother so she knew
him and she was kind of like oh it's
fine you know the girl can go with him
they were just going on an errand or
something like that and then the girl
never returned now they didn't find her
for almost a month they found the little
girl's decomposed body in an abandoned
building she had been raped
was tied up with cords and I really had
no fear of being caught because you know
yeah okay so he was kind of doing that
going out in a blaze of glory type yeah
I'm gonna rape and kill everything
ya got and he got this woman his
girlfriend to go longer all of this - so
that was May 29th 1984 that was when
they abducted that the nine year old
girl so then about a month later the two
of them were in Gary Indiana and they
see two little girls walking down the
streets a nine-year-old girl named Annie
and her niece who was a seven-year-old
girl named Tamika and they were just
going to the store to get some candy or
something like that broad daylight right
so Alton Coleman and Deborah Brown they
ride up to these two little girls on
their bikes they're like oh we have some
clothes that you might like that we can
give you and stuff they lure these two
little girls into the woods and then
rape and batter both of them one of them
survives Annie okay she's knocked out
they think she's dead they try to
strangle her and stuff but um they think
she's dead and they leave her there but
she later on wakes up and is able to go
to a house and go to police now she gave
the police a very very detailed and very
good description okay and at this point
there's been kind of a thing where
because he had been in prison so many
times before and he had gone under a
couple different aliases so they had
pretty much triangulated they knew who
this guy was but he was crossing
straight state lines like all the time
so they had to kind of I mean this is in
the eighties so the FBI had to get
involved in all this other [ __ ] right
now the same day that they found the
other little girl the little seven year
old Tamika they also found her also
there was another woman named Donna
Williams that she was 25 and she was
from Gary Indiana also and she vanished
they found her on July 11th in Detroit
and they found her car about a half a
mile away so she had also been raped and
she was killed by strangulation so
basically what they're doing is they're
just going from state to state and
raping and killing just anybody or if
they need a car they will go there kind
of their MO was because they were a
couple because he was very charming he
was a smooth talker
they would usually go up to a house if
some
was selling something or they would
befriend people like at one point they
befriended some people they met in
church and there was one couple where
they went where they were selling a
camper that was in their front yard and
they went up asking about the camper and
then ended up beating the [ __ ] out of
them and raping the wife and killing her
and all this killing the man
so we [ __ ] like that so there was
another in Dearborn Heights Michigan
they also beat a couple not to death but
they think this guy is is he a big guy
no we don't know I think he looks I
don't know he looks pretty thick yeah he
didn't have any fear of attacking that
couple just in the open well like I said
he would because he had a woman with him
and they were both seemed very friendly
they would usually insinuate their way
in this actually this next one this is
very disturbing this happened on July
5th and this at this point they were in
Toledo Ohio
now Alton Coleman makes friends with
this woman named Virginia temple and she
had four children five children so they
said the two of them they make friends
with this woman at church she invites
them over to her house for dinner and
then a couple days later people are like
we haven't heard from her in a while
they go over to the house and they find
two of her younger kids I think what I'm
was eight and when I was three were over
to her son's and they were in the house
freaking out they were just like
terrified they wouldn't answer the door
when police came and so like finally
finally they talked him into the police
to talk to kids in the letting them in
in the kitchen there's just blood all
over the kitchen there's like a trail of
blood leading down to the basement they
go down to the basement they find
Virginia temple and the nine-year-old
daughter that had been raped and
murdered and stuffed into crawl space it
was a couple of days so the kids were in
there a couple days ago stand back as
far as I know yeah his name is Alton yes
oh let me go you here do you [ __ ]
nasty he's dead all right you did yeah
yeah I don't like that no I know yeah so
yeah so it's just like I said this whole
this whole [ __ ]
is just so convoluted it's just that
basically what they're doing they're
going people's houses either raping them
killing them beating them stealing their
car taking their car a little for a
little while man abandon it then they
either ride on bikes or steal another
car or whatever another girl a 15 year
old named Tony story she was in
Cincinnati she disappeared and eight
days later was found raped and murdered
so at this stage I mean the FBI are
really trying to catch these people but
they don't really know where they're
going and because their crimes are so
random right they're just targeting
anybody it's just whoever happens across
their path if they need a car if they
need money they're just like oh well too
bad for you so they're trying to
establish a pattern but it's very
difficult and it seems like the FBI were
always like a couple of hours behind
them yeah now at this point sounds like
to me he's got no plan this is just like
I said it's just they decided to go on a
spring of buying client type one
documentary I watched about them they
actually said that maybe because like I
said he was a piece of [ __ ] before he
even met this woman almost kind of
sounds like a Starkweather yeah that's
what I mean it does seem like that and
because this spree occurred the start of
its occurred right before he was
supposed to go to trial for raping a
fourteen-year-old girl they think that
that was actually some kind of stress
and any that was like the catalyst right
yeah I just said I'm just gonna take off
with my girlfriend and we're gonna do
all this [ __ ] and like I said she seemed
like a willing participant also I mean
she did be who was guilty was gonna go
to prison so you figured had another
lose ya know who's gonna take everybody
out with it yeah so the FBI I guess you
know how the FBI had the ten most wanted
list well evidently if someone's really
horrible and they need to catch them
like today yeah they will make a special
11th place on that list for this
particular person and that's what they
did for him all right now they they did
media saturation and they said now what
we want to do they're sober not we're
sure where we're going next
but usually what spree killers will do
if they'll go on the run for a while but
he's like almost inevitably they will
head back toward home because they get
tired of running they want to go back to
a place they're from
with so they were kind of expecting them
to do that like I said their whole
entire spree it was 54 days was how long
they were on the run and as I said they
killed multiple people beat multiple
people raped multiple people they didn't
get caught until they indeed came back
to Evanston Illinois which was familiar
territory to them is very near where
they were from and they happened to be
walking in a park called Mason Park they
had with him a bag they kept every few
blocks they would walk and they would
change their shirts and hats and so like
they thought they would be recognized
yes yes yes so they're walking across to
Mason Park and a guy happened to drive
past in his car and he recognized Alton
Coleman has he gone to school with them
right so that's what you get for driving
back to your hometown yeah hey all your
nasty boy you said yes so so this guy
drives by in the car and sees him and
he's like holy [ __ ] so he drives across
the street calls the cops and the cops
came and they actually they didn't
struggle they gave false names at first
but they were like yeah right we know
you are and then they searched them they
found a knife on him they got on her and
they arrested them now the problem was
that because they had committed crimes
in so many states pretty much every
state was like let me Adam you know I
guess so this would be 20 years of
handing him from one state to the next
that's actually not what is happening um
because he had done some murders in
Michigan but at that time Michigan had
the death penalty that Michigan said
well you know you one of you guys with
the death penalty can have him he was
actually given four separate deaths
death sentences in different states that
has ultimately given to Ohio I think as
far as I know at the time he was the
only criminal to ever be given that many
death sentence isn't that many different
states
yeah and it he was actually executed in
2002 he's just a piece of [ __ ] like
starved where they're really yeah same
kind of deal now deborah was kind of a
different story
she initially got the death penalty also
in Ohio but in 1991 her sentence was
commuted they argued that she had
diminished responsibility because she
because her IQ was so low and
stuff like that now initially she didn't
seem like all that remorseful but later
on she kind of changed her tune so
evidently she is still in prison serving
a life sentence okay so like I said this
show is going on very long but I have to
talk about these two [ __ ] also
okay because these two are [ __ ] girls
[ __ ] and this also kind of brings up
your favorite topic was it necrophilia
a little bit I'm just one your head then
alright so like I said I'll just go over
this really quick okay these two Doug
Clark and Carol and Bundy the Sunset
Strip killers I've never heard of it
okay no boy this guy I have yes just
doesn't ring a bell
Doug Clark came from a military family
he himself was in the Air Force he got
out of the Air Force in the 70s and he
was kind of a barfly type of guy he was
he called himself you know love this the
king of the one-night-stand oh [ __ ] like
he thought he was a sexual so here's the
same type of thing going on Carol Bundy
his partner in crime she was another one
who seemed to have a really bad abusive
childhood her mother had died very when
she was quite young her father then said
oh well now your mom's dead you have to
take her place so and then started
molesting her when she was like 11
then when the dad remarried they kind of
shipped her off to foster homes like
that so my get out right now and by the
time she was in her late 30s she had
already been married three times and all
of the husbands were abusive that's a
disaster
she was she actually worked as a nurse
for a while but her eyesight got so bad
that she couldn't work anymore she
couldn't get glasses well it it was some
kind of thing I don't know if she knew
because I think that it was before she
it was after she met Doug that he took
her to to a doctor and everything and
she actually ended up but she got this
big coke bottle glasses right so yes so
she had these big huge coke bottle
glasses she was kind
overweight not a very attractive woman
they must be said so by the time she met
the Clarks she was about 37 years old
and he seemed like he saw her coming you
know I mean because he's like oh here's
somebody again that I can it'll do
whatever I say they have the ability to
sniff out the weak link there yeah it
really does seem like that so they
actually met at a bar called little
Nashville now at this bar there was also
a guy that had been singing there so she
had actually been having an affair with
this singer at the little Nashville bars
it was the Jack Murray and he was
married and stuff but he apparently
apparently that didn't stop them right
the sad thing now Jack Murray had
actually stolen a bunch of money from
her okay
so and she had also tried to bribe his
wife to divorce him so she could happen
damn with 15 dollars that's it yeah
maybe that's also you trying to buy them
man right she's just trying to buy that
man for $1,500 but yeah it was a [ __ ]
up situation all around
so Doug Clark meets Carol Ann Bundy in
this bar they find out that they both
have kind of a predilection for kinky
sex so something that Doug Clark was
super induced in the BDSM he was you
know warns more sisters clothes and [ __ ]
like that
he had all kind of sex toys and when he
found Carol Bundy he found someone who
was willing to go out and rent
prostitutes so they could have
threesomes and things of that nature one
of the people that he had some sexual
interest in was a neighbor of theirs who
was 11 damn and Carol was actually able
to you know kind of convince this little
girl to come over there and like hang
out with them and like Rick took a
taking gross as pictures and so after
all this kind of prostitution [ __ ] then
Doug Clark reveals to her well you know
I've always had a fantasy about killing
a woman while I was having sex with her
so I can feel her vaginal contractions
while she was dying and all that kind of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] right now so instead of
her being like [ __ ] bad about you know
what I mean she's like oh it sounds like
a plan right right so at this point Doug
Clark stalks her stalks Carol Bundy
into buying them two pistols you know so
they'll be in her name they said he's
thinking ahead and so she called them
the toys oh yeah that 225 caliber
pistols weirdo where is this happening
this was in California yeah
now at first Doug Clark actually killed
two girls by himself he went out and he
picked up two teenagers named Gina
neuron oh and Cynthia Chandler they were
stepsisters they were runaways
they had Broadway from Huntington Beach
I think they were 15 and 14 or 15 and 16
or something like that
Sakhalin girls did that evidence yeah so
he apparently picked them up on the
Sunset Strip made them give him a
[ __ ] each and then shot them and then
dumped them by the side right driver one
at a time I guess they were both in his
car need to shot him
and he dumped him by the side of the
road so they were found the next day now
he told Carol about this now to her I
don't want to say to her credit even
though that's what I just said right she
did call the cops at first mmm but she
didn't give her name or anything she
said well my boyfriend is maybe
responsible for those murders she wasn't
there but you told her about it but then
when it kind of before the cops were
like well more details and she was hung
up right so then about like a little
more than a week later Doug Clark is
doing the same [ __ ] he's cruising the
Sunset Strip he sees two prostitutes
Karen Jones and exxie wilson now Karen
Jones was simply found in a gutter on
the side of the road with one bullet
through her head XE Wilson was found
near a dumpster behind a restaurant with
no head you will not be edified to know
what they were doing with that head oh
yeah but I'm afraid that I will have to
tell you right now the head was found a
few days later in a box okay but in the
interim Doug had been keeping the head
in the freezer mmm Carol would get up
every day and put makeup on the head so
that Doug could use it for various yeah
yeah
I know you wouldn't like that this
woman's nuts yeah she's totally that's
crazy and she's crazy yeah so then like
a few days later like I said they they
put the head in the box like they
wrapped it in a t-shirt from one of
their other victims that they even know
about yet right and they left it in a
box and some porn dude found it yeah
he's just like open the box he's like oh
that's so weird looks like a pine box
and things like oh there's a [ __ ]
head and they're goddamnit you know name
okay so then three days after this poor
girl's head was found they found another
body in the woods near San Fernando
Valley
this girl was 17 her name was Marta net
comer it looked like she'd been dead a
lot longer than the other one so they
think that this was maybe Doug Clark's
first victim that they know about cuz
like I said he probably killed a bunch
more people that they know how about now
here's where any idea that Carol Bundy
was not into this yeah kind of goes out
the window right okay because remember
how carol bundy was super into that into
this Jack Murray got it was her
ex-boyfriend yeah now after all these
killings that Doug Clark have been doing
Carol decides she's gonna go to the bar
and see Jack Murray and she starts like
telling him about stuff that her and
Doug Clark have been doing like I don't
know if she was confessing or if she was
just saying listen this cool [ __ ] you
know what I mean I don't really know I
don't know because what happens then is
Jack Murray is kind of like man that's
[ __ ] up and then implied that he might
go to the police and narc on her hmm
so then she lures him out to his van
like let's go have sex in your van and
she shoots him in the head and then cuts
his head off and takes it home and shows
it to dumb what takes it home in a
garbage bag
yeah she says to him hey I brought Jack
home and he's like what the [ __ ] I don't
like that guy this other [ __ ] and then
she opens the bag and they're like oh
hilarious now here's the dumb thing
evidently it wasn't a case of her being
like oh you're my ex-boyfriend oh you
stole my money or all this other stuff
she only took his head evidently because
there were bullets in his head and she
didn't want the bullets getting back to
her but the stupid thing is that not
only did she leave his headless body in
the van she also left the show
right
not exactly a master criminal and not
only that but two days after that she
couldn't take it and she basically told
her co-workers that she had killed the
guy so of course they called the cops
now they ended up finding the two guns
their two guns and they had matched all
the ballistics and everything to all
these victims so they found these two
guns at Doug Clark's work like hidden
behind a brick wall he pulled out some
bricks or something
so they found it in there okay so they
go on trial they're both trying to blame
each other for it
although the creepy thing is that you
can see they're still there's some video
of her being interviewed yeah and she's
so [ __ ] casual man yeah she says some
she says stuff like I don't mean that
like sound like a psycho or anything I'm
not I don't think I'm a psycho but she's
like killing it's kind of fun like on
the roller coaster she yeah and she just
looks like this middle-aged kind of
housewife fee right it's so creepy
losers yeah I mean he crazy I mean he
looks creepy he looks like a serial
killer
he has like these creepy shark eyes and
everything like he looks like you know
he's a suit and he's all skinny and
everything but he looks like a serial
killer but she just looks like someone's
mom you know what I mean it's totally
bizarre damn that's nasty yes yes so
basically Bundy got charged with two
murders Jack Murray because she
confessed to it and she also confessed
oh we killed this other prostitute I
don't think they ever found or they did
find the body but they don't think they
ever identified her but she said she was
there for that murder so they did get
her for that one
Clark was actually charged with six
murders he tried he was one of those
ones where he thought he was [ __ ]
clever right so he's like I'm gonna be
my own attorney one of those guys and so
he tried to paint himself oh I was a
totally innocent it was all her idea and
Schillinger is like no yeah yes so yeah
he got done for six so he was sentenced
to death in 1983 although he has not
been executed yet he is still on death
row now Bundy just much like Karla
Homolka also did a plea bargain she said
I'll tell you everything if he give me a
lesser sentence they still gave her life
though she did die in prison she died in
2003 from heart failure she was 61 but
Clark is still alive he's still in
prison
so yuck yeah they were also oh I forgot
to the heart to Clark you're [ __ ]
nasty yeah oh and also he had been the
two girls that he killed initially the
two Runaways he had also been keeping
them in a storage garage and raping them
as the dead body so I thought you would
like to know that because I know for our
foreign listeners the United States does
not like this just these girls the
reason that this comes up is because
this shit's writer and especially I was
I was watching the thing when I was
watching a lot of the FBI profilers and
stuff like that talking about the
dynamics of like couple killers they're
like well you know serial killers are
fairly rare they're like a couple serial
killer is very very rare yeah and the
reason you keep hearing about the same
ones is because there's not that many
yeah because it's just something that
doesn't happen all that much yeah
cuz like I said is free freakazoid yeah
and it's like I would think it's very
very hard to get two people that are
into the same kind of [ __ ] that happened
to meet each other and go hey let's go
on a killing spree or hey let's start
raping and murdering people at random
but anyway alright so this is gone way
too far too long sorry about that but
like I said it's the Valentine's Day
special it's a special occasion and I
wanted to get all of this stuff in and I
didn't realize it would take that long
but we hope you enjoyed this creepy
true-crime Valentine's Day show and if
you like the show please remember to
Like share subscribe and share with all
your friends share on your social media
tell everybody about it if you want to
support the show please remember to go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcasts and you can
give us a monthly donation or if you
would like to give a one-time donation
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com and there
is a link in the sidebar to a PayPal
account where you may do that if you
wish
also remember to go to zazzle.com slash
13 o'clock and check out our t-shirt
designs I also have a new leg tote bag
that I just made with our logo on it and
we're looking for a new microphone hey
we're looking for a new microphone a
face not what one that's better than
this $50 one it sounds like ass it
sounds like we're in a teen can all the
time I try to fix it but you know so I
guess that will do it for this
Valentine's Day episode have a good
Valentine's Day all you lovers out there
don't kill anyone see you next week bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]